in fat news doritos has new flavors
right so they got a ketchup and mustard
flavor yuck but i'm understanding it
from reading about this stuff because
oreos does this too they come out with
ridiculous flavors
as a marketing ploy to make you want to
buy the original and and it's like a
market study that it looks like so when
doritos comes out with just nonsense
flavors you go to the store and then you
go
mustard
mustard doritos and you go i don't want
that nonsense and then you go get some
cool ranch you know
what is the original doritos flavor is
it like i don't even know what the
original doritos flavor is because i
always think of cool ranch and then that
other one
um not sure